Saturday night at the Guggenheim Museum
in New York City tourists and art lovers
taking advantage of the free admission
hours when suddenly a blizzard of white
leaflets and banners denouncing the
Center
[Applause]
the protests all led by a group called
pain prescription addiction intervention
now a group founded by famed
photographer nan goldin
who joined the so called dyin on the
floor of the Guggenheim all part of an
effort to demand this museum and others
like it around the world give back the
millions of dollars the settlers have
donated to them the Guggenheim did know
was coming
nobody busted us nobody spoke we don't
even use emails very guerrilla action
that's the word
[Applause]
oxycontin almost killing me golden told
me that her efforts against the sackers
are all very personal that she herself
was addicted to oxycontin for some three
years the drug first prescribed for her
she says after our wrist injury suffered
in Germany and I ended up locked in my
apartment it almost killed you
oh my god
I was on massive doses and my whole life
was obviously counting four years the
Sackler family has been one of the great
patrons of the Arts around the world
even before their company began making
oxycontin there's a Sackler wing at the
Louvre in Paris at the Victoria and
Albert Museum in London
there's the secular courtyard and the
Sackler centre a sackler Gallery in
Washington a Sackler Museum at Harvard
in New York the Metropolitan Museum of
Art's temple of dendera is housed in the
Sackler wing and down the street at the
Guggenheim there's the Sackler Center
for Arts education is it fair to ask the
museum to give back the money one thing
but they can take down the name
they can justify all themselves they can
make a point that they're going to
refuse future funding not just do it
silently but speak out the protest came
as the investigation of the settlers and
their company Purdue Pharma appears to
be picking up speed
we found that Purdue misled doctors
patients and the public about the real
risks of their dangerous opioids
including oxycontin the Attorney General
of Massachusetts Maura Healey released
her own blizzard of documents the result
of a lawsuit she brought last year
against both the company and eight
members of the Sackler family who served
on the Purdue Pharma board their
strategy was simple the more drugs they
sold the more money they made and the
more people died we found that Purdue
engaged in a multi-billion dollar
enterprise to mislead us about their
drugs Purdue pushed prescribers to give
higher doses to keep patients on drugs
for longer periods of time without
regard to the very real increased risk
of addiction overdose and death in a
court filing the Attorney General
revealed the speech that Richard Sackler
the senior vice president for sales gave
at the launch of oxycontin the launch of
oxycontin tablets will be followed by a
blizzard of prescriptions that will bury
the competition he said the prescription
blizzard will be so deep dense and white
that Gulden's group says it wanted to
create its own blizzard of white
leaflets in the protest at the
Guggenheim documents released by the
Attorney General what does that tell you
attempting murder it tells me that it's
not just money
I mean its money to appoint the Attorney
General also made public an internal
email written by Richard Sackler when he
was president of Purdue Pharma urging
company officials to shift the blame to
the people addicted to oxycontin we have
to hammer on the abusers in every way
possible
they are the culprits and the problem
they are reckless criminals Nan Goldin
says her group is emboldened by the
documents being revealed by the
Massachusetts Attorney General it's been
almost a year now
since they began their protests and so
far no museum has heated their call to
return the Sackler money the biggest
target being the Metropolitan Museum of
Art in New York where the group returned
once again this week we're here to call
out the Sacco family who've become
synonymous with the opioid crisis we're
here to call out out all the museum's to
allow the Sackler name to line their
halls tarnish their wings who honored
the family who made billions off the
bodies of hundreds of thousands we came
here a year ago we're knocking on their
door they've done nothing my son
Jeffrey was prescribed oxycontin for a
knee surgery in high school he wanted to
wrestle that season and the doctors told
them you can do it if you take the pills
every four hours take them before the
pain starts take them on schedule they
caused me believing what the doctor said
to
be an accomplice to my son's death when
my son talked of his pain I said did you
take your pill
I became an accomplice to my son's
demise that's not right
the Metropolitan Museum of Art says the
settlers have been generous patrons for
almost 50 years that the museum is
currently engaged in a review of its
gifting policies a spokesperson for the
Sackler family declined to comment on
Mangold the protest or the allegations
she made against the family the company
itself Purdue Pharma says the Attorney
General's complaint is riddled with what
they call demonstrable inaccurate
allegations as for the Guggenheim Museum
our request for someone to appear on our
program tonight was also declined we are
now joined by Barry Meyer who has a
reporter for The New York Times has done
much of the groundbreaking work on
oxycotin and the role of Purdue Pharma
and the sacrify
he is the author of the book painkillers
an empire of deceit and the origins of
America's opioid epidemic also joining
us by Scott is Rob reach a professor of
political science at Stanford University
and director of the university's McCoy
Center for Ethics in society mr. rishe
is also the author of Just Giving why
philanthropy is failing democracy and
how it can do better
professor Reiss let me start with you
and ask you what do you make of Nan
Goldin
protest against the major museums that
carry the Sacre name it's a fantastic
activist effort to get more people to
pay attention to the long-standing and
hardly novel activity of people who make
a lot of money and then seek to enhance
or sometimes cleanse their reputations
by giving generously as philanthropists
and I think it's appropriate or Nan
Goldin and all activists to force the
Guggenheim Museum and any other place
that's taken money from the Sackler z--
to make a public statement about why the
museum or the nonprofit entity wishes to
be an accomplice or to be complicit
in the reputation laundering of the
Sackler family you'd call them an
accomplice for taking the money and
putting up the day certainly they're
complicit in the kind of public spirited
generosity that the Sackler wish to be
known for else they might not have
wanted their name to be put on the side
of all of the buildings and on the
various halls that are the recipients of
their philanthropic gifts now of course
the settlers themselves have not been
charged with the crime the company did
plead guilty to a felony count of
misbranding that the individuals of the
sacrum
is it fair to label them in this way
no well there I'd say it's too early to
say but if they are convicted of crimes
then I think the situation for the
museum's changes dramatically because
we've gone from the act of complicity in
reputation cleansing or laundering to a
new situation in which effectively then
the money received from the Sackler z'
is akin in my mind to something like
stolen goods and I mean here's an easy
way to think about this that if if I
take your watch Brian and I go down to
the pawn shop and sell it and then I
have a bunch of money from your watch
and I give it away to a super effective
nonprofit organization like the
Guggenheim Museum and I tell you look at
all the good that I've done but the
money that I got from your watch you're
just a complaint to me is I don't care
about the good that you're doing give me
my watch back and repair the harm that
you caused and one thing that the
Guggenheim Museum might consider doing
if the Sackler czar convicted of actual
crimes is not merely taking the Sackler
shame off the building not merely giving
the money back to the Sackler family but
giving the money to the victims of the
people who have died from oxycontin
scandal Barry Maher let me ask you
what's the status of the investigation
does the Attorney General of
Massachusetts have the goods you know
it's it's partly a little too early to
tell Brian these are lawsuits for just
starting to see these documents emerge
but what's startling in this law
story I mean a story that's been going
on for almost 20 years is we really are
getting one of our first glimpses inside
Purdue Purdue for many years has kind of
created the narrative that the Sackler
family was sort of these beneficent
owners of Purdue they sort of were
hands-off but now we're seeing that they
were hands deep in the micro management
of the company
these internal emails with Richard
Sackler especially I really do tell the
story that you've been telling for years
there it's stunning I mean you know I
first ran across the Sackler as 20 years
ago and learned about Richard Sackler
and and heard about his activities but
the callousness if that's in fact the
what he was expressing or the view that
only you know bad people would get
addicted to this drug is is sort of
ridiculous because sadly there are
patients people that were customers of
Purdue Pharma who became dependent
and/or addicted to these drugs and with
the Purdue Pharma company now say and
the Attorney General's complaint is
false are trying to vilify unfairly the
company and its executives and they
point out that of all the opioids sold
only 2% are oxycontin and that most of
the deaths now come from aerelon and
fentanyl well let me just say as a
general rule when it comes to Purdue
Pharma they've had a history of blowing
smoke up until the time that they were
criminally convicted of lying to doctors
lying to patients they claimed they were
innocent as snow they claimed that they
were abiding by the laws I would take
anything they say with a grain of salt
and they have also always from the very
beginning tried to minimize their role
in this crisis the fact of the matter is
as Richard Sackler so amply pointed out
they wanted to take over the market for
narcotic painkillers in the United
States that was their goal that was
because they wanted to profit from this
market they wanted to blow away the
competition
and they did it and there was huge havoc
as a result and the death toll now some
say as many as 400,000 well I mean
that's the overall death toll it's hard
to know how many of those you can assign
to oxycontin and I think it goes beyond
the actual death toll I mean we've
become very fixated on death and
overdoses but there are you know
thousands of patients in this country
probably tens of thousands of people
whose lives have not been changed for
the better from using oxycontin they've
been changed for the worse because
they've become physically emotionally
and psychologically dependent on this
drug they've lost you know their ability
to live daily and they would be far
better off if they were given other
types of pain treatments professor Reese
let me ask you given all of that and the
museum certainly have to know that why
have they not heeded the calls to take
the names out well there's a tension
that any leadership of a nonprofit
organization has all nonprofits need to
raise money to carry out the missions
all the nonprofit leaders are invested
of course and thinking that the mission
that they're pursuing is a good one and
if they can raise money from people that
haven't been convicted of crimes and
that they can extend some social
recognition - well that's common
practice in any large nonprofit
organization now with all these
questions raised but the Sackler family
I think the leadership of the various
museums and cultural institutions need
to say something about why in the light
of these allegations they're willing to
nevertheless accept the money and I mean
to be fair to people who work in
nonprofits substandard University where
I'm sitting is one such example one
occasional attitude is that the problem
with tainted money is that there just
ain't enough of it and what excuses the
pursuit of the nonprofit's acceptance of
the money is the goodness of the mission
of the nonprofit and that you can
somehow separate out the means of making
the money and then the good that's done
once the philanthropic
has been made and as I said before I
think when actual crime has taken place
that separation is no longer tenable if
I do really good things with stolen
goods that has nothing at all to do with
the badness of my initial theft in the
case where a theft hasn't yet been shown
or a crime hasn't yet been shown as with
the Sackler these are just accusations
or allegations as I understand them then
I think the appropriate thing to say to
the leadership of the museum's is that
in light of the allegations what will
happen if they are convicted
what will the museums do and secondly
given that the name still adorn the
buildings are there any lines that a
museum would draw in accepting money
from people who are tarnished in the
public eye professor rish thank you very
much very much thank you very much for
being with us again we asked both the
Sackler family and its company Purdue
Pharma that have someone on our program
tonight but they both declined to do so